welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka homielander and
this video we're answering some of the
big questions you may have about the
boys
since posting my finale breakdown i've
had numerous comments asking the same
things
so i thought i'd put them all together
in one video just to go over absolutely
everything
now this includes whether stormfront is
alive or dead what she said at the end
whether vic can actually kill homelander
and a lot more
there will be heavy spoilers here but i
tell you what mate if you clicked on a
bloody video about the ending of the
boys on a channel called heavy spoilers
you can do one as far as i'm concerned
anyway yeah make sure
make sure you like the video and don't
forget to subscribe
as let's face it it wouldn't be the
worst thing that you've done
anyway with that out of the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the video
okay so the first thing you probably
want to know is can victoria kill
homelander
i know that because it's the thumbnail
of the video and also
because i watch you as you sleep now
it's a pretty significant question
and one that a lot of people still
wonder about especially
because they will likely be facing off
against each other at some point
i've gone through both seasons in a big
re-watch since the second one ended
and i think the first season especially
drops several clues that lean towards
her being able to
now firstly translucent is a big
indicator of how the
fight would go in season 1 we learn that
he has invulnerable skin
and cannot really be damaged from the
outside however
the boys shove a bomb up his butt and
well the writing is on the wall about
that one
along with the rest of him in addition
to this stormfront is stabbed in the
finale through the eyes by becca
and this severely damages her too even
though we know that she's pretty much
invincible as well
so from this we can take that when it
comes to soups
things like organs and parts not
protected by the skin
are actually very vulnerable if you can
get to them from the inside
then you can beat them and this was also
demonstrated by black noir
after he swallowed a pine nut what not
these nuts
now as for vick's powers i can't show
the clips of her bursting heads because
youtube will demonetize the video but if
you slow the footage down on her attacks
you can see that they explode outwardly
and not inwardly
making me think that she bursts heads
open from the inside
thus i would say that there's a pretty
strong chance she can kill homelander
much in the same way that she did
shockwave who too should also be
invulnerable
now when homelander arrives at her rally
she doesn't take her eyes off him
and at the courtroom she's pretty much
always looking at someone
just before they die thus i would say
that there's a pretty strong chance she
can kill homelander
but you know what deep down i hope he
just lasers her before she gets
the chance to now i've seen a lot of
back and forth over whether vic is
working with four or not
but after a second watch through it
becomes clear that she is
is that a is that a question do we do we
need to put this in a in a question
somewhere
is is vic with fort yes she is
now firstly she kills rainer to cover up
the awareness that there's a coup from
the inside
in the van hui and frenchie ask who can
explode heads like that
and we then cut immediately to her in
edgar's office
edgar is watching her on a rival news
network instead of vnn
and she also pretty much prepares
lamplighter's speech
to help implicate stormfront rather than
the company
i told you stormfront gave the orders i
just executed them
it was um it wasn't easy
she also likely calls together the
entire hearing in order to draw people
out that will betray bought
vic kills adana after it's discovered
that he has sensitive information on the
7
which could destroy the company if
leaked to the public
in addition to this we just have to look
at the source material to see that she
is indeed
vote and paid for yes i know i use that
joke on another video
i don't care though she isn't really
anything like a comic book counterpart
he too was a political figure that vo
used to get into the white house
so that they could have their products
bypass laws it seems like they're going
the same way with vic
and it's such a good twist that i didn't
see coming at all
and those are the main clues and her
goal the entire time is to pretty much
raise the super terrorist threat
so that v is released to the public as
edgar tells butcher
this will raise the stocks at vaught and
make the company
so rich they can probably buy amazon as
she tells butcher
he's done more in regards to stopping
bought than she has
and this is true because she's basically
done f all
i think this is why they don't mind
losing stormfront in the end
as she was pretty much just a tool to
help fuel public hate
and get things to a certain point beyond
that it's all politics
and speaking of stormfront the character
did say some stuff in german for her
final words on
screen and these translated to it was so
beautiful
how the three of us sat there in the
shade of the apple tree
do you remember that dave frederick
chloe's arms out the car window
we found the perfect spot by the river
in the shade of an apple tree
it was the first time chloe ate fresh
apples it was so happy
it was wonderful i never wanted it to
end
now this is obviously referring not only
to her daughter chloe
but also her husband frederick bought
because she's speaking in german
this is likely before the trio moved to
america
there's some irony here as at the time
the german forces were separating jewish
families and concentration camps
and both stormfront and her husband were
complicit in mass genocide
this memory is reminding us that those
stormfronts seem like a great person on
the surface
she's actually just the worst yeah i'm
talking about how i felt about her in
episode one yeah not
not episode five or whatever now they do
say that when you die your life flashes
before your eyes
and it is likely that stormfront is just
retreating to a happier memory before
she passes away
but is she dead can we can we get some
text on screen for that
and also for the the german final words
like something like
what did she say in german but but put
it earlier in the video obviously and
never mind look
homelander does state that she has been
neutralized and is being held in an
undisclosed location
so she could indeed be alive in kicking
if the creative team need to bring her
back
however what vort tend to do in the
comics when one of the characters die
is that they cover this up and sort of
create a pr stunt
here they state that the hero died
saving the world or something
and this is solely done so that the
characters seem invincible
and it's also possible that they put
that in place here so that the general
public
doesn't get any idea of revolting now
personally
i do think that she's still alive and we
did see from the boob scene
that she can heal from burns so i do
expect her back at some point
we also know that the character gekko is
able to regenerate limbs
so should she need to stop being so
bloody armless
there is a way to make her a threat once
more the first episode of season 3 is
actually titled payback
and this could hint towards what is
going to be happening in the comics
stormfront was actually part of a group
called payback
and they were pretty much a parody of
the avengers now the name payback could
also hint out what's going to happen in
the entry
obviously the soups will want revenge
for what happened in the series
so this payback could also be literal we
do know that soldier boy is going to
feature heavily in season 3 as well
and as he was one of the main members
there it could be a big reunion with him
in stormfront
that's all just a theory for the moment
though and lastly
a lot of people want to know whether
black noir is alive
don't don't bother with that a question
on the screen for that no yeah yes he is
and though he's unresponsive in a
hospital bed that doesn't mean he's not
there
black noir is pretty much the strong and
silent type anyway
so him not talking doesn't really mean
that much
now not to spoil too much of the comics
but noir is integral to certain parts of
the ending
and though i do think that they're
diverting from this heavily he will
still
likely be around for the ending he's
also probably one of my favorite
characters in the show so yeah don't
don't write the guy out just yet yeah
he's a bloody top-notch bloke
he's got a heart of gold and if you only
got another guy
you'd see why i love him as much as my
own flesh and blood
anyway obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on that
and if you have any other questions then
make sure you drop them below
if you enjoyed this video then please
click the thumbs up button and not the
thumbs down one yeah
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of 52 insane details that we
noticed in season 2 of the boys
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
and when it's going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also become chapters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
bye